from
because we
seal everything, we
continue to work without electricity,
water and heat, there are small nuances with the
provision, namely, there are not enough analgesics now, in
general, we have already been at the
workplace for more than a week, someone else is even more
so, like this, we
continue to work everything in their places
[  music]
many can’t be returned and the
blow is big I don’t know that in culture
not to understand everything has become so dark everything is
blurry trying to get up you can’t fall
crawling I understand the leg despite it you don’t
understand the leaves started no
crawling turning over I see legs and
there is Serezha behind me with our turnstile  I was
also told the
case is very scary I really hoped for
these sentences for the first round for 2
I hope they agree on something
there is no food delivery in general people take
everything in a row empty shelves in stores
[music]